In the entire history of the Soviet Union,
there was not a single planned and peaceful
leadership transition.
Of the eight Communist Party Secretaries in
the nearly seven decades between 1922 and
91, six ruled until they died, one was overthrown,
and Gorbachev saw the dissolution of the entire
state.
In fact, there had never been a peaceful handover
of power in any major Communist country…
until the early 2000s, when Chinese leader
Jiang Zemin voluntarily resigned.
For the first time in the nation’s history,
there was no coup, no intrigue, no political
infighting.
Jiang Zemin even endorsed his successor, despite
having not chosen him.
No one was calling China a liberal democracy,
but it seemed as though the days of one-man
rule were finally over.
Term limits were instituted.
Anyone over the age of 68 was expected to
retire.
And each successive leader — from Mao Zedong
to Deng Xiaoping to Jiang Zemin to Hu Jintao
— was less powerful than the last.
The phrase being floated around at the time
was “intra-party democracy”.
In other words, there may only be one party,
but within it, there was plenty of room for
healthy competition.
From here on out, policies would be debated,
leaders would rotate out, and the “best
ideas” would win.
…Then, one man — Xi Jinping — reversed
all this progress.
Xi is about to begin his third term in office.
And with neither a designated successor nor
hardly any competition, there’s no end to
his rule in sight.
So, how did China revert from “intra-party
democracy” to one-man rule in a single generation?
How does any of this — the Chinese Communist
Party — actually work?
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula.
Nebula is the only place you can watch all
PolyMatter videos, including my ongoing series
“China, Actually”.
For just $15/year with the CuriosityStream
and Nebula bundle, you can watch all five
of those videos — over 90 minutes of exclusive
content — and much more to come.
Every five years — typically in October
or November — about 2,300 people from across
China travel to the Great Hall of the People
in Beijing for what’s called the “National
Party Congress”.
This year, for example, is the 20th Party
Congress, which began on October 16th, 2022.
Because it’s designed to appear representative
of society, most of these 2,300 people — called
“delegates” — are relatively low-ranking
party members.
They include everyone from farmers to celebrities,
factory workers, and mayors.
Likewise, to create the veneer of harmony,
ethnic minorities are awkwardly paraded around
in their traditional dress.
The whole thing is a giant spectacle.
There are giant red curtains with golden tassels
and more clapping than an American State of
the Union.
The party takes no risks in the run-up to
the country’s most important political event.
VPNs, which, although illegal, are ordinarily
tolerated for use by foreigners and the technologically
savvy — suddenly stop working.
Dissenters are preemptively put under house
arrest.
Police patrols are doubled.
And private businesses — both Chinese and
foreign — are warned not to rain on the
party’s parade by making any major announcements.
Yet, for all this showmanship, the actual
event is exceptionally boring.
It may be theater, but not the kind anyone
would voluntarily watch.
On the first day, for instance, the Party
Secretary delivers a looong speech called
the “Political Report”, reflecting on
the past five years and setting the priorities
for the next.
It’s here that you’re reminded how incredibly
Leninist the Communist Party still very much
remains.
Rather than specific policies or plans, you
might hear about the “Three Represents”,
“Four Comprehensives”, or “strengthening
of confidences”.
It’s only by deciphering these vague slogans
that China-watchers infer where the country
is headed.
It’s an entire language of its own.
After this, the 2,300 delegates, quote, “study”
the speech, and inevitably accept it without
challenge.
That’s because the real decisions have been
made much earlier.
Although the party doesn’t acknowledge this
fact, officials meet in secret at a summer
resort east of Beijing in August.
The second item on the agenda is to amend
the party’s constitution.
Again, no laws are being written here, only
ideological statements.
In 2017, for example, Xi Jinping’s name
was added — implying that he’s not just
another politician, but a great figure in
party history.
Finally, at the end of this week comes by
far the most important task, when delegates
“elect” members of the Central Committee.
“Elect” in quotes because, remember, almost
everything has already been decided.
In 2017, delegates had 222 candidates to choose
from for 204 seats, giving them the option
to reject just 9%.
Those 204 people then became members of the
Central Committee, the next level up in the
party hierarchy.
There are almost as many “alternates'',
who attend meetings but aren’t allowed to
vote.
They can replace full members when they die
or lose their positions.
The Central Committee meets at least once
a year in what’s called a “plenum” — and
the first plenum occurs the day after the
Party Congress ends.
This year, on October 23rd.
Their most important task is to elect members
of the 25-member Political Bureau — or Politburo
— another level up in the party hierarchy.
The Politburo, in turn, “elects” a Standing
Committee of usually 7 or 9 people — one
of which is the General Secretary of the Party.
In this case, Xi Jinping.
Notice the phrase “General Secretary”,
not “President”.
China is a Party-State, which means it has
a government and a single ruling party.
The two mirror each other in many ways, but
they aren’t the same.
The state, confusingly, has its own version
of the National Party Congress called the
National People’s Congress.
And to make things even more confusing, multiple
parties participate in the People’s Congress
— not just the Communist Party.
But they’re all members of a single “United
Front”, which means they co-exist, not compete
with the CCP.
Anyway, just as the Party congress helps elect
a General Secretary every 5 years in the Fall
on the Party side, the People’s congress
elects the country’s President and Premier
every 5 years in the Spring on the State side.
Though, don’t think of the party and state
as entirely separate, either — there’s
lots of overlap.
Virtually everyone working for the Chinese
state is a Party member, but not all Party
members work for the state.
Afterall, there are nearly 100 million party
members.
As General Secretary, Xi Jinping is head of
the Party.
And as President, he’s head of state.
These are two different roles that could be
filled by two different people.
But they’re not, which gives him the choice
of which to use at any given moment.
When Xi visits a foreign country — unless
that country is, say, Communist Cuba, or North
Korea — he does so as the “President”
of China.
That’s technically true — he is, in fact,
the President.
But there’s a growing movement in favor
of always calling him “General Secretary”.
In China, the Party is above the state.
The People’s Liberation Army reports directly
to the Party, not the government.
A city’s Party Secretary is given the license
plate number “1”, and its mayor, “2”.
Trivial as this may sound, it is telling.
The CCP even has its own, separate justice
system.
In other words, Xi Jinping’s most important
titles are General Secretary and head of the
military, not President, which is mostly a
ceremonial role.
The common use of “President”, many argue,
is a deliberate strategy on China’s part
to obscure the Party’s importance.
It wants to appear to investors like any other
country, not one where your private property
might be confiscated for political reasons.
But, in truth, even the title “General Secretary”
is a bit misleading.
In most countries, a person’s position in
government is what makes them powerful.
Joe Biden is powerful because and — (for
the most part) — only because he’s the
President of the United States.
Sure, former Presidents are celebrities, but
fame is not to be confused with power.
This all probably sounds exceptionally obvious.
But it’s not true in China.
Take an example: Have you ever heard or seen
a photo of Deng Xiaoping?
What about Zhao Ziyang?
Chances are the answer is ‘yes’ to the
first question and ‘no’ to the second.
Deng is the iconic pioneer of China’s reform
era, while Zhao is forgotten by all but students
of history.
Yet Deng Xiaoping was never General Secretary,
Zhao was.
Instead, Deng is referred to as a “Paramount
Leader”, an informal nickname, not an official
position.
When Deng famously traveled to Shenzhen calling
for more economic reform, he was 87 years
old and fully retired yet powerful enough
to steer the country’s direction.
You don’t need any specific title to wield
considerable political power in China — even
the most political power — and, conversely,
neither does holding any specific title guarantee
power.
The “watershed” moment in Chinese history,
when Jiang Zemin peacefully handed over power
to Hu Jintao in 2002, is not quite what it
seems.
In reality, Jiang quietly stayed on as head
of the military until he was heavily pressured
to step down in 2004.
Like China’s “embrace” of Capitalism,
the party’s conformity to consistent rules
and norms has always been a mix of both our
wishful thinking and their skillful performance.
Even age limits — which were seen as a positive
sign that no one would be allowed to rule
forever, turned out to merely be a way for
Jiang Zemin to purge his rivals.
And the limit has been broken when convenient
since.
When China made headlines in 2018 for removing
term limits, that was for the office of President.
There have never been term limits on Party
Secretaries, meaning Xi Jinping could’ve
already stayed in power indefinitely.
What all this means is that in China, power
isn’t automatically conferred by office
— it has to be won.
Its leaders generally arrive relatively weak
and slowly try to consolidate authority over
time.
It took Jiang Zemin nearly six years to wrestle
control after being named General Secretary.
Hu Jintao arguably never did.
What makes Xi Jinping unique is not so much
his hunger for power but the speed with which
he acquired it.
As we’ve seen, there were very few actual
rules preventing him from accumulating power.
It was simply a question of political skill
and luck — both of which he had in droves.
Xi is what you might call a “princeling”
— his father was a revolutionary fighter
and high-ranking Party official.
Meaning, as a child, he had both privilege
and, likely, a sense of entitlement — his
“red-blood” made him “destined” for
the throne.
Now, make no mistake — princelings have
shifted in and out of favor over time.
As a teenager during the Cultural Revolution,
Xi was sent to “learn from the proletariat”
by doing manual labor in the countryside.
He lived in a cave, and his father was arrested.
Later, after Mao’s death in 1976, princelings
were “revived” as the party revisited
its past.
Xi, like many of his elite peers, landed a
promising job in government.
But unlike his peers, Xi Jinping kept his
head down.
Thanks to their connections, princelings had
no trouble securing jobs, but very rarely
were they promoted to the very top, where
their superiors thought they might cause trouble
or even threaten to replace them.
Instead, says expert in Chinese politics Victor
Shih, they tended to promote, quote, “always
nice people” — weak cadres who obediently
followed orders.
Xi, on the other hand, avoided the spotlight
by taking relatively low-profile jobs outside
of the city — where he quietly climbed the
ranks.
By the time he reached the apex of power in
2012, not only was he better connected than
most of his peers, but, ironically, he also
benefited from this discrimination against
princelings — he didn’t have much competition!
These are all the Politburo members before
he became General Secretary — ranked according
to the size of their political networks — basically:
his competitors.
First, we can remove anyone due for retirement
— they, obviously, aren’t much of a threat.
Next, let’s remove all the non-princelings,
who lack the connections and privileges.
Institutional sexism effectively disqualifies
all women.
We can also remove this person because of
a reputational stain — his brother defected
to the United States.
That leaves Xi with only 3 major competitors.
Bo Xilai was subsequently arrested, and the
other two were quietly demoted to the unimportant
Vice President position.
He then reorganized the military, launched
an enormous anti-corruption campaign that
helped purge rivals, and enshrined his name
in the party constitution.
Today, Xi Jinping is effectively unchallenged,
making him more powerful than any Chinese
leader since Mao.
Yet, Xi is not Mao.
The challenge to understanding China is learning
from its past without losing sight of the
present — which is what I try to do in my
Nebula Original series “China, Actually”.
Each video we try to solve a puzzle about
China — like why some protests are tolerated
and others not, or why it’s still trying
to maintain zero cases of COVID in late 2022.
You can watch all these full-length exclusive
videos and more to come on Nebula, the streaming
service myself and other educational creators
founded where we don’t have to worry about
the algorithm.
Nebula is partnered with CuriosityStream,
which is home to great documentaries on science,
nature, and history — like this true story
of one of the Soviet Union’s most notorious
spies.
When you sign up for CuriosityStream for just
$15/year with the link in the description
or on-screen now, you also get free access
to Nebula, where you can watch my videos and
countless other exclusive Originals, ad-free
videos, and bonus content.
And for the record, that’s not just a trial
— you get access to both services for the
same low price, as long as you stay subscribed.